[Music]
okay here we go
[Music]
throughout the battle of the space race
between the united states and soviet
union
both unions experimented with remarkable
and experimental technologies
in the pursuit of the data and wisdom
required
to conquer this new frontier the task of
gathering this data itself was a
tremendous challenge that required new
aircraft
capable of reaching the edge of space
and pushing the boundaries of human
understanding one plane that stands out
during the ascent
of the space race was the x-15 a plane
designed to be the first
to break into the hypersonic regime and
climb past the carmen line
100 kilometers above the earth's surface
and break into space
the plane would help nasa develop the
materials needed to survive the intense
heat of re-entry
the structures needed to ensure
stability and control
in the hypersonic flight regime and the
development of control mechanisms for
the vacuum of space
while providing the impetus to develop
several new technologies required
to allow humans to survive the vacuum of
space
like the first of its kind fully
pressurized space suit
this was the world's first space plane
the plane laid the groundwork for both
the apollo program the space shuttle
and the sr-71 to this day the plane
holds the record for the fastest
ever crewed flight with a top speed of
6.7 mach
leaving even the sr-71 in the dust
as this rocket-powered plane powered
through to the edge of space
this is the insane engineering of the
x-15
when the x-15 was first proposed in the
1950s
no other aircraft came even close to its
proposed capabilities
in both max altitude and max speed the
closest any previous plane came
was the x2 which topped out at a max
speed of market 3.2
less than half of the eventual record
the x-15 would achieve
the x-15 wasn't a step forward in
capabilities
it was a tremendous leap that would
require the best minds in nasa
or the naca as it was called then
the first step on this road to the
record 6.7 mach
was developing an engine capable of
powering such an aircraft
and for this the designers had to turn
to rocket propulsion
even the advanced hybrid engines of the
yet to be developed
sr-71 couldn't push into the hypersonic
regime
and no air-breathing engine would be
able to function
at the altitudes the x-15 was targeting
the engineers knew the engine they
required would need to produce around
240 kilonewtons of thrust at sea level
with an ability to vary thrust output
while fitting into the narrow body of
the plane
this powerful engine did not exist and
developing it would prove to be one of
the greatest challenges facing the x-15
the first problem to solve was this
variable thrust output
which was desired to give pilots more
control over the aircraft
and allow for testing at various speeds
blasting straight into the hypersonic
regime
without extensive testing at lower
speeds would have proved
disastrous as the difficulties of
frictional heating
were yet to be solved older engines like
those of the bell x1
the first plane to break the sound
barrier achieved
variable power output by simply
selectively igniting
four separate combustion chambers this
provided
stepped power output but not true
throttle
the x15 needed finer control than this
and needed to achieve it without adding
significant weight and complexity to the
engine
added complexity would decrease the
safety putting any pilot in danger
while any added weight would
significantly reduce the maximum
altitude
the plane could achieve the x-15
achieved this control
by varying the speed of its turbo pump
which is the pump which forces the
oxidizer and fuel
from their respective storage tanks into
the combustion chamber
pumping fluid at the rate a rocket
consumes it is actually
a tremendously difficult challenge the
x-15 carried
8 165 kilograms of fuel
and oxidizer which the plane burned
through in
85 seconds that's 5897 kilograms per
minute
that task would require a powerful pump
and that pump
would need a powerful energy source now
it may seem like an obvious choice to
simply use a portion of that rocket fuel
to power the pump and indeed this is how
modern rockets like the spacex merlin
engine
power their turbo pumps turbo pumps
operate by spinning a turbine
using hot fast flowing gas but using the
products of rocket fuel combustion
in a spinning turbine would quickly lead
to severely melted and broken turbines
the combustion products of rocket fuel
are simply too hot for this application
the merlin engine gets around this by
using a very fuel-rich mixture
for the turbo pump pre-burner which
leads to incomplete combustion
and lower exhaust temperatures that
exhaust has a large portion of useful
fuel
contained within it but the [ __ ]
exhaust is not suitable for addition
to the main thrust chamber so that fuel
is simply dumped overboard
you can see that fuel rich study gas
coming out of the exhaust here
on the merlin engine the x-15 used an
entirely separate fuel to power its
turbo pump
a monopropellant like hydrogen peroxide
decomposes in an exothermic reaction
when in the presence of a catalyst in
this case
hydrogen peroxide was passed through a
silver screen catalyst
which caused the hydrogen peroxide to
decompose into oxygen
and superheated 737 degrees steam
it was this superheated steam that drove
the turbine
and the speed of the turbine could be
controlled by simply adjusting the
amount of hydrogen peroxide
passing over the silver catalyst with
the use of control valves
the exhaust of this system was then
simply dumped overboard
through this exhaust port this was not
the only use
for hydrogen peroxide on the x-15
a similar system powered the auxiliary
power system
or apu which powered the plane's
electronics the pilot would also need
some form of control when outside of
earth's atmosphere
where the plane's aerodynamic control
surfaces would no longer work
so the plane was fitted with thrusters
on the wing tips
and nose to provide control while in
space
these thrusters were also powered by
hydrogen peroxide
using hydrogen peroxide to power the
turbo pump came with some challenges
this turbine operated two separate
impellers
one for the liquid oxygen storage tank
which operated at 13 000 rpm
and one for the anhydrous ammonia tank
which operated at 20
790 rpm these different pumping speeds
ran on the same drive shaft
which necessitated gearing to achieve
the appropriate fuel mixtures
but also incorporated serious safety
concerns over
accidental fuel leakage from the
respective hydrogen peroxide
liquid oxygen and anhydrous ammonia
alliance
as a spinning shaft is more difficult to
ensure an adequate seal
double seals were placed between each
section in an effort to prevent mixing
while a system of pressurized helium
purged the system
the choice of liquid oxygen and
anhydrous ammonia
was an interesting one this engine
needed to be powerful
extremely powerful and getting it to the
required thrust levels
was going to need the right fuel and
oxidizer combination
when speaking of rocket power
capabilities one of the first stops is
specific
impulse specific impulse describes how
efficiently a fuel can convert its mass
into thrust to understand this let's
first look at the total impulse
which describes the thrust force
generated over the entire burn period of
the engine
we can graph this rather easily by
plotting the thrust the engine is
providing
in each second of its flight that may
look something like this
the total impulse is found by finding
the area
under this graph which gives us the
total energy the rocket released
this is a useful metric in itself but
specific
impulse is better because not all
propellants are born
equal two different fuel and oxidizer
combinations
could provide the same total impulse but
we need to consider the weight of the
fuel and oxidizers themselves
after all the initial weight of the
rockets is always dominated by the
weight
of their own fuel to find the average
specific
impulse we divide the total impulse by
the total propellant weight
the rocket expelled going by this metric
a liquid hydrogen and liquid oxygen fuel
mixture is
by far the best hydrogen has the lowest
molecular weight of any known substance
each hydrogen atom consisting of just
one electron and one proton the h2
molecules
used in the liquid hydrogen fuel has a
molecular weight of just two
while rp1 the kerosene derived fuel used
for the spacex merlin engine
has a molecular weight of 175. however
molecular weight is not the only factor
in determining specific impulse
we also need to consider a multitude of
other factors
like fuel mixture ratios combustion
temperatures
pressure ratios and specific heat ratios
this is where a nice simple specific
impulse value
gives us a clearer understanding of how
much thrust per unit weight
a fuel and oxidizer combination could
potentially provide
without delving too much into the
complicated physics and chemistry
and looking at this value hydrogen is
best
at around 381 seconds at sea level
while the kerosene and oxygen
combination of the merlin engine
has a specific impulse of about 289
seconds
however it's once again not as simple as
picking the highest specific impulse
value
because hydrogen has a very low density
meaning we need a much larger volume
tank
it's also a difficult fuel to handle as
it will boil
off if allowed to rise above its
extremely cold
boiling point of minus 250 degrees
celsius
requiring insulation boil off valves and
last minute refueling
to boot this tiny molecule can seep out
of the tiniest holes
even the gaps between larger molecules
of seemingly solid metal
despite its potential hydrogen was not
ready
for this task but would soon be put to
use
for the very first time with the centaur
upper stage
after many years of development hiccups
there was a great deal of
experimentation
during this period to find a fuel and
oxidizer mixture
that would provide the specific impulse
needed to get the plane to hypersonic
speeds
and it wasn't just a matter of loading
the most powerful fuel
and oxidizer combinations into the fuel
tanks
increasing the specific impulse is
directly linked to elevated combustion
chamber temperatures
since fuels with higher impulses
generally release
more energy when ignited this is one of
the major hurdles
engineers of this era had to contend
with
as the materials and designs needed to
survive these extreme temperatures
simply did not exist the traditional
fuel of the time
was a 75 alcohol 25 percent water
mixture
with a liquid oxygen oxidizer which has
a specific impulse of about 269 seconds
not high enough the water was added into
this mix
primarily to reduce the combustion
chamber temperature
which of course reduced the impulse of
the engine
to achieve that higher specific impulse
the engineers needed to figure out a way
to allow the engine to survive the
elevated temperatures
that would come with a higher impulse
fuel and the only way to do that
was by finding better materials or find
a way of
actively cooling the engine ideally both
one way they achieved this was through
regenerative cooling
regenerative cooling uses one of the
propellants usually the fuel
as a cooling fluid the fuel will be
pumped
through heat exchange piping that wrap
around parts exposed to dangerous heat
like the injector nozzle thrust chamber
and nozzle
where it can draw heat away from the
metals it comes in contact with
before being injected into the thrust
chamber
this was not a new concept the v2 rocket
which used that 75-25 alcohol mixture
also employed regenerative cooling but
the heat transfer rates were not
terribly high to be an effective cooling
fluid
the fuel needs to have a high specific
heat capacity
meaning it can absorb a lot of heat
energy before its own temperature rises
water
has a high specific heat capacity of
about four thousand
two hundred joules per kilogram kelvin
meaning
it takes four thousand two hundred
joules of heat energy
to heat one kilogram of water by one
kelvin
we also want the fluid to have a high
latent heat of vaporization
which means it takes a lot of energy to
vaporize the fluid
we don't want the fluid turning into a
gas in the cooling tubes
here water is strong again boiling at
100 degrees celsius
and that number will be even higher when
pumped under pressure
so now we are looking for a fuel that
not only has
a high specific impulse but with great
cooling properties too
kerosene was considered with a slightly
improved specific impulse of 289
over the traditional alcohol water
concoction
and was cheap and freely available at
the time
however when passed through cooling
tubes kerosene of this era
had a nasty habit of forming clumps of
impurities
this process is called polymerization or
coking
and accelerated when exposed to the heat
of the cooling tubes
which could clog the thin tubes and
cause major problems
the rp-1 grade kerosene fuel we use
today
was developed to combat this problem by
removing the impurities from the fuel
hydrazine which has a specific impulse
of about 303
was also considered but it had a nasty
habit of exploding
when used in regenerative cooling as its
exothermic decomposition process
can start at a temperature as low as 97
degrees
which can lead to a violent explosion
eventually the engineers
who may have been short a few fingers at
this point landed on anhydrous ammonia
as their fuel ammonia is a fantastic
cooling fluid with an extremely high
heat capacity
and high latent heat of vaporization
making it
the ideal rocket fuel for regenerative
cooling
with a higher specific impulse over its
alcohol water
ancestors at 293 seconds
however ammonia does come with its own
issues it's toxic
and would attack many metals like copper
the pressure gauges of the x-15
which contained copper were consistently
failing after six months of use
despite not being in direct contact with
the fuel
this was annoying but deemed an
acceptable trade-off for the fuels
benefits
this development process of the engine
was fraught with difficulties
and ran over both time and budget
meanwhile the airframe had to undergo
parallel development without the final
engine instead
using two xlr 11 engines which had
previously powered the bell x1
these provided enough power to get the
plane to 3.3 mach
and test some of the plane's flight
performance characteristics
but fell well short of the requirements
for hypersonic flights
in the meantime data on the hypersonic
flight characteristics of the x-15
were gathered using advanced hypersonic
wind tunnels
but the engineers had no idea whether
this data would be accurate
this was still a very new field of
research
the design and requirements of a
hypersonic aircraft that could possibly
fly into space
were so radically new and different that
traditional aerodynamics textbooks
had to be left at the door this was
going to require
a completely fresh approach with all
assumptions thrown out
for example during the development of
the x-15
a debate was raging in the naca ames
research facility
over the design of the nose for
hypersonic aircraft like this
julian allen argued that any aircraft
flying in this flight regime
should be designed with a blunt body
something that completely contradicted
the established thought of the era which
demanded for
extremely pointed nose in an effort to
reduce drag
julian allen argued that this blunt body
design would create a bow shock wave
which would create a boundary layer of
air around the vehicle
and ensured the extreme frictional heat
was kept away from the structure of the
aircraft
and instead dissipated harmlessly into
the atmosphere
the x-15 did incorporate these ideas
into
all of the planes leading edges
including the nose and wings
and the idea would be applied to all
re-entry vehicles in future
as the x-15 re-entered earth's
atmosphere
it would be taking a very high angle of
attack approach
to bleed off speed at a 20 degree angle
of attack
the upper vertical tail became
completely useless
as it was severely shielded from the
airflow by the body of the aircraft
whereas the lower tail would experience
a marked increase in effectiveness
as it dipped into the high pressure zone
caused by the compression side of the
wing
so this lower tail was essential for
ensuring yaw stability
at these high angle of attack re-entries
but
this lower ventral tail was so large
that it made landing on the plane's
shorter skids
impossible so the pilot had to jettison
a section of it before landing
where it would deploy a parachute to
land softly and hopefully
undamaged the shape of the x-15's
vertical tail
is one of the most distinctive features
of the plane the primitive looking wedge
profile looks like something someone may
have designed with 300 year old
knowledge
of fluid dynamics oddly that's exactly
what it was designed with in 1687
newton described an equation in his
groundbreaking book
principia that predicted the force a
flat plate in a moving fluid would
experience
he imagined the air as a stream of
particles that would strike the plate
and transfer all of their momentum
normal to the surface
and then travel parallel to the plate he
also assumed the particles did not
interact with each other
and there was no random motion this of
course
is wrong the complex fluid fields in
this situation
are much more complicated than newton
predicted but bizarrely his equation
rather accurately
approximates the forces on an
aerodynamic surface
in hypersonic flow let's look at the
wedge tail surface
as it increases its mach number at
supersonic speeds a shock wave will form
at the point of the wing
this is called an oblique shock wave and
its angle becomes smaller
as the mach number increases until
at hypersonic speeds the angle becomes
so small
that it almost matches the wedge angle
this looks oddly a lot like what newton
predicted for subsonic
airflow and indeed his equation becomes
more and more accurate as the mach
number increases
and while the wedge shape begins to act
predictably
with this simple equation normal thin
curved aerofoils
designed with subsonic fluid dynamics in
mind begin to experience
a dramatic loss of lift rendering them
essentially useless at hypersonic speeds
the wedgetail continues to perform and
provide the stabilizing pressure
needed to keep the plane flying straight
this does come with a trade-off of high
drag
as the blunt end creates a narrow
pressure zone
behind it that drags the plane backwards
but this was of little concern for a
short range plane
that needed to slow down quickly in fact
the wedge tail was fitted with
extendable speed brakes
to even further this braking effect when
coming back from its high speed runs
flying at hypersonic speed did not just
come with strange aerodynamics
the heat of hypersonic speeds was one of
the largest challenges that faced the
x-15
a very specialized metal was needed for
the task
the sr-71 utilized titanium and it
experienced a maximum temperature of
about 300 degrees celsius
on its pointed nose and engine inlet
spike
during mach 3 flight this temperature
was vastly lower
than what the x-15 was expected to
experience at mach 6
and above the effect of frictional
heating does not scale linearly
it would not be dealing with 600 degrees
but upwards of 1000 degrees
far beyond what the titanium skin of the
sr-71 could handle
having to deal with the extreme external
heat was difficult enough
but the designers also needed to contend
with the extreme
cold emanating from the internal
cryogenic liquid oxygen fuel tanks
in images of the underside of the x15
you can frequently see frost covering
the belly of the plane
where the liquid oxygen tanks are
located there is only one metal on earth
up for this task in canal x
inconel x is a nickel chromium iron and
niobium alloy
that was capable of operating at lower
temperatures while having
extremely good heat resistance plotting
tensile yield stress
against operating temperature for
aluminium titanium and stainless steel
looks something like this now if we plot
in canal x we can see just how good it
is at maintaining its strength
at extremely high temperatures however
inconel is heavy
designers estimated that an inconel x
airframe would weigh about 180 percent
more
than an equivalent airframe made from
aluminium
and this was before the ablative
materials were applied
to allow for the highest speed runs the
ability to maintain its strength at
elevated temperatures
was beneficial but there were plenty
more problems to solve
non-uniform heat distribution made
accommodating
thermal expansion and stress extremely
difficult
and several redesigns of the plane
structure was needed to fix
problems that cropped up along the way
during the plane's first
mach 6 flight one of the quartz windows
quite worryingly
shattered mid-flight when the in-canal
framing buckled
due to thermal expansion thankfully only
the outer pane shattered and the pilot
survived to tell the tale
the framing metals were promptly
switched to titanium
which experiences lower thermal
expansion
and the aft portion of the framing was
removed entirely
for a very interesting reason the
designers discovered during high-speed
tests
that the plane was experiencing extreme
local heating in strange locations
one such hotspot was appearing behind
the window and it was the result of
shock waves creating turbulent flow
these turbulent flows create areas of
elevated heat transfer
into the skin of the aircraft that
create dangerous hot spots
to find and eliminate these hot spots
the designers employed a special kind of
heat-sensitive paint
that would change color when exposed to
certain temperatures
after one high-speed flight the plane
returned with wedge-shaped patterns
emanating from the leading edge
expansion joints which were small gaps
in the leading edge
to prevent buckling when the inconel x
expanded
during flight these gaps were creating
this turbulent
flow and to fix it engineers installed
small strips of inconel x
over the expansion joints in an attempt
to minimize the turbulent zones
they did get smaller but were not
eliminated completely
for the eventual world record breaking
flight the inconel x
alone would not ensure survival of the
plane
for this the plane would need an
ablative material
a sacrificial material designed to
gradually burn
and fall away from the aircraft pulling
the heat with it
one of the principal missions of the
x-15 was to develop
these materials multiple materials and
application systems were tested
throughout the x-15 program and plenty
of problems were found
bonding the ablative materials to the
surface of the metal
proved difficult some simply fell off
when the underlying metal expanded
underneath it
and it could not stretch with it these
problems were found at slower mach 5
flights
but if they appeared during the top
speed attempt the plane likely would
have been lost
another problem arose when the ablative
material after burning away from the
nose of the plane
began attaching itself to the windows of
the plane
making it extremely difficult for the
pilot to see
which was a bit of a problem the
engineers looked at
several solutions to the problem one
involved
deliberately exploding the outer pane of
the glass
to remove the ablative stained portion
the engineers eventually landed on a
less risky solution by installing a
mechanical eyelid
to the left window that remained closed
until the high speed portion of the
flight concluded
ensuring the pilot had at least one
window to look out of
during landing this was a relatively
primitive solution and created some
stability issues
as once open the eyelid acted like a
canard
and caused the plane to slightly pitch
up roll rice and yaw rice
an annoying but manageable problem a
slightly more terrifying problem cropped
up with the final ablative material
this pink material called ma35s
was sprayed onto the surface of the
plane in various thicknesses
according to the local need it worked
well but had one
massive glaring drawback when mixed with
liquid oxygen the material would become
explosive
and could be triggered by a slight
impact a bit worrying considering the
plane's oxidizer was liquid oxygen
and spillage was not rare especially as
the plane had to be continually topped
up from its b-52 dock
as it ascended to altitude the spray-on
method could also potentially introduce
the ablative material
into the oxidizer lines too to minimize
this terrifying prospect
the plane was sprayed with a secondary
white sealant coat
to prevent the liquid oxygen from mixing
with the ablative
and came with the added benefit or
disadvantage
of hiding the glorious pink color after
a decade of development
on the 188th flight of the x-15
the plane was finally ready for its
record-breaking flight
on october 3rd 1967 william knight
climbed into the cockpit of the x-15
hanging from its perch underneath the
wing
of the behemoth b-52 which carried the
plane up to 45
000 feet here nice dropped away and
ignited the rocket engine
and with the help of two external fuel
tanks they roared for two
and a half minutes pushing the plane to
the yet to be broken
6.7 mock flight in the attempt the plane
was destroyed
the ablative coating hadn't worked as
well as hoped and the plane landed with
parts of the skin
melted away it would not fly again
the remaining two planes in the program
flew just another 11 times in total
before the program was shut down through
the 199 flights of the x-15
nasa gained some of the most valuable
data it has ever gathered
the x-15 not only broke speed records
but altitude records
when on july 17 1962 robert white
became the first man to fly a plane to
space
the knowledge nasa gathered through this
program advanced our understanding in
rocket engine design
turbulent flow localized heating
ablative materials
and hypersonic stability and control all
of which contributed
to the design and development of the
mercury gemini
apollo and space shuttle programs and
provided neil armstrong
with invaluable experience in
controlling a rocket-powered spacecraft
armstrong was a fascinating man someone
i knew very little
about until i watched this documentary
on curiosity stream
an hour and 40 minute long documentary
that had me captivated
the whole way through i was inspired by
the story of a young boy who became
fascinated by model aircraft
at an early age and pursued that passion
with every step of his life
becoming a licensed pilot at the age of
16
entering an aerospace engineering
program at 17
through a military scholarship before
being drafted
as an aviator into the korean war a
stepping stone to his eventual career
as an experienced test pilot and of
course
astronauts a life of a man driven by a
deep passion for aviation
that led him to a life of greatness that
will never be forgotten
this documentary alone is worth the
astoundingly low price of subscription
to curiosity stream at 1479 a year
or 299 a month but this is just one of
many award-winning documentaries
on curiosity stream and you will also
get access to nebula
the streaming service that's home to my
logistics of d-day series
my new podcast modulus which launched
another episode today
and ad-free versions of all of the
videos you see
on this channel i am just one of many
channels on nebula
and you can get exclusive access to
originals from my favorite channels
like mustard the origins of stealth
which details the fascinating history of
the f-117 nighthawk
or wendover productions three-part
trivia game show that i took part in
this is simply the best way to support
the channels you enjoy
while getting something awesome in
return if you are looking for something
else to watch right now
there is a playlist to the entire insane
engineering series on screen now
along with a link to real science's
latest video about the incredible
efforts we are making
to program bacteria to take on our most
difficult problems